ron desantis who again got the funds
passed in the budget to do just this and
is now doing exactly what he said which
is what we always ask politicians to do
well he's got some non-word salad when
it comes to talking about what's going
on right now hitting their chests when
trump was president saying they were so
proud to be sanctuary jurisdictions
saying how bad it was to have a secure
border the minute even a small fraction
of what those border towns deal with
every day is brought to their front door
they all of a sudden go berserk and
they're so upset that this is happening
and it just shows you you know their
virtue signaling is a fraud okay
they
they are supporting policies that are
just frankly indefensible it is not
defensible
for a superpower to not have any control
over the territory of its country over
the borders of its country and he
inherited a situation where you didn't
have this happening and yes we needed to
build the wall there was more that we
needed to do he reversed the trump
policies knowing what would end up
happening and you know one of the
reasons why we want to transport because
we obviously it's expensive if people
are coming here you gotta it taxes
social services and all these other
things
don't you guys just love hearing truth
like when it's just so obvious it's easy
it's pleasant you can breathe it's nice
you know interestingly he makes a great
point there about the virtue signaling
okay we all get that but the point is
it's very easy for all of these democrat
mayors and governors to say we're
sanctuary cities and states when the
border actually works like it did under
trump now the border doesn't work and
suddenly they're very upset about that
uh viva you're in florida now very
exciting to be here wouldn't you say i'm
witnessing it in real time you know
firsthand uh but you know hearing
desantis talk it's easy to speak freely
when you're speaking the truth he
doesn't have to mince his words he
doesn't have to cover up for past lies
uh you know at one point in time i
remember seeing it from from the north
uh talking about building a wall was
racist talking about uh problematic
immigration was racist and they said it
now that they've come through
busing them to sanctuary cities is
racist or according to burns hitlerian
and then they say we need a we need a
border policy that works it's only when
the problem the policy problem hits
their front yard that they start making
sense like whoopi goldberg to some
extent uh you know now we need policy
that works now let's be civil with each
other but until the problem gets to our
front door we are politically rabid and
we are uh you know politically partisan
to the extent that anything you propose
that would have otherwise been a
rational logical solution we're going to
frame as racism bigotry xenophobia
whatever to demonize you
sarah do you feel like people in texas
are uh who maybe were on the fence about
abbott or you know there's this weird
there are democrats in texas it's weird
like do you think people are getting it
there maybe
uh yeah absolutely especially when
yeah especially when the alternative is
of course robert francis o'rourke who is
going to do absolutely nothing to at
least try to correct this problem in
fact he would just
let more people in uh and already you
know in already uh you know towns that
are are already suffering so i do think
that it has uh it has strengthened
people's uh ideas that yeah you know we
can't we can't afford to vote any other
way except governor abbott i wouldn't
say that anyone is particularly
passionate about governor abbott uh as
people perhaps are in florida but he'll
do you know he'll he'll do much better
over over robert francis o'rourke i do
want to go back to uh to kamala as well
it's just so fascinating to see the
stark contrast between
kamala harris answering a simple
question you mentioned she was asked if
the border was secure uh you know
several i think it was last week and her
answer was just you could tell she's
literally coming up with every single
word in that moment she has absolutely
no idea where she's going to go to and
then you have ron desantis who is the
exact opposite and gives a very cohesive
uh correct answer i also heard i can't
remember if it was eric adams or lori
lightfoot earlier this week say we need
a national solution guess what guys we
have a national solution it's called
enforcing the border laws that already
exist and the fact that they can't
comprehend that is just amazing to me
there is a national solution
the border states are already trying to
get that done so perhaps now that this
has been dumped in your backyard maybe
you will now agree that we have to
enforce our borders every other nation
does it we are no different and it is
unsustainable to do anything different